if pac-man was a real living organism
and party time wait what
[Music]
we start today like I start every day
wrapped up in covers oopah brought us
some great bedspreads this one would
make me feel less lonely this one's
great for parties and this one looks
like it does the opposite of cover you
thanks to videogame look-alikes calm the
Lich King looks like the witch-king the
doom guy looks like GI Joes Copperhead
Cybil Bennett looks like Cameron Diaz
and Mario looks like Stalin but none of
those can beat real-life girls dressed
up like Jessica Rabbit Manifest gave us
40 of them of course when in doubt samus
burlesque I wanted to buy my own samus
costume and my friend told me to use the
cook islands google domain so I went to
Google Doc Ock
and wait what at least this girl's
birthday is nice and she's got a normal
cake wait what Obama help me out wait
what
drip fist showed us 25 ill-advised
t-shirts but when the shirts come off
things get even better
crazy body shaming some are nerdy some
are classy some are romantic some are
superheroes and well there's this one
too want to see what chicken nuggets
look like before they're molded into
Nuggets shapes well here you go
mmm chicken paste the only thing worse
than that are male [ __ ] stamps but as
pop crunch showed me even chicas can get
it wrong as you read this [ __ ] stamp
the unique jerky way our eyes move will
cause these static swirls to seem to
actually spin yesterday to Daily Mail
posted this photo a photographer at the
Ryder Cup was actually hit in the chest
by Tigers shot but managed to take this
picture right before he got mail it's
cool but um how awesome is this guy so
awesome in fact that he's been used in
one of my favorite practices vertical
comics where we zoom in on the best face
make sure we get really close and then
zoom out to view complete facial
domination some of these are fun but
creepy some are pretty much lizard
no garbage one of my favorite bands I
see what you did there
Vieira submitted this picture on our
Facebook page
there's a cat hidden somewhere in it can
you find the cat you can click here here
here here here and here to watch
previous episodes of IMG thanks for
watching
wait what